[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we got Casey here as our special
guest we never have them here you know
what's crazy is that we we haven't had
you like in front of the camera and all
of a sudden every [ __ ] time now I'm
here you're all in front of the camera
actually I should not come [ __ ] you
people like it though just kidding
no it's just the observation I just
recently made because I got so used to
Casey sitting there you guys don't know
behind the camera and the Casey cam was
really fun right but then after a while
I got so used to him like close I
thought he was a part of the cast and so
the transition was like just normal to
me until I recently realized you've been
consecutively not only here but also
hosting and all this [ __ ] and highly
involved in front of the camera and then
the other day I was asking y'all like
Amen like so you want to host and then
you're like whoa it actually takes a lot
out of me cuz you know my introverted
ass and I was like oh I totally forgot
about that cuz you seem so natural on
camera the whole thing is like perfect I
could fake it til I crash that's usually
how I do it every one of those yeah you
know I go to the bar you go to the club
you never faked orgasm yeah I mean you
crash yeah how do you nine or Josh you
got you gotta have to orgasm to crash
there I think an orgasm do you do that
no just stick it on a chick have had sex
too long where your your dick my dick
gets too numb to even reach orgasm yeah
so then I'm like oh [ __ ] I gotta end
this but then I don't want to like make
her feel bad that she couldn't like make
me finish or whatever so I'm like
[Laughter]
she's probably like year that mean it
worse I think you just say my dick is
numb I don't think I could bust well you
know when you're a teenager you're full
of like you know [ __ ] pride or
whatever yeah so Lee so you're sure he
made you come though like that would be
a perfect excuse it's like yeah you made
me come way too much just no more in the
well yeah wells dry yeah they're like
when was it and you know I'm like oh
it's inside good luck
Stacy will you come for us right now no
no please
you want to see you how he comes I want
to hear how he comes I wanna hear how he
did it how we did it with that chick he
goes what if we all do it together what
we should all come together right now
that sounds really hot I guess I can't I
can't do a fake orgasms your fake orgasm
I don't have one I I think I think it's
real one sounds fake what do you think
it sounds like like some karate noises I
don't know she's [ __ ] Bruce Lee the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you never watch another
person a movie ever the same way ever
again you know certain people when they
come they exhale to the point where they
lose all of their breath because they
like to time the the pushing of the boat
you know in porno what I [ __ ] hate is
when the guys coming the cameraman has
to show his face I need that - why does
he want his dick shoot yeah I don't want
to see your face are you watching
there's a lot of we're the guys like
it's usually gay parties about the
bhattacharya watching porn and they're
like it gets the cubby scenery like why
haven't the girls came in yet who's the
girl that Joe's like why they cut into
this guy's face why aren't they cutting
to his coming dick that's what he just
said okay yeah coming dick on the face
or cream pie or whatever I'd much rather
see that then [ __ ] a guy like about
the buzzing you're like yeah let me time
it correctly and then it cuts to his
face and I'm coming and the [ __ ]
visual is a man's face and it kills my
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude the Irate tap as tone
in your voice tells me that this happens
to you a lot he's [ __ ] fed the [ __ ]
off it's tired of it water there isn't
many I have to do it thank God for the
[ __ ] double tap 10 seconds
flash-forward yeah I feel you though are
they if they're us they're not
attractive I'm like oh [ __ ] just don't
show you they're [ __ ] why do you why
do you feel gross dad it's a guy so I'm
very particular about them eat even a
girl's face yeah what are you like
seeing then you just body parts on what
kind of a like I don't want to see your
face just the same way to tip is more
like I just want to see the body parts
don't want to put a face and human
behind it I love seeing the dudes faces
while they're [ __ ] Manning dude it's
the best [ __ ] ever why you're jacking
off for for comic oh just for comedy as
well both you want to go here get techno
the comedy is good I feel like sometimes
when I hear that stuff I'm like wow you
guys come in Tam's Lee or is that for
show okay I was about to ask you that
cuz for girls like I I like watching
masturbation videos but I don't like
looking at the girl's face because I
just know it's all fake can you guys
tell when the guys busting and it's all
fake or you can't even your eyes the
guys busting I don't think that's fake
yeah there's there's a physical evidence
so real like he's playing it on yeah
yeah yeah sometimes I'm like this he
kills it what you're just saying what I
want to do you play I'm being pleasant
we got to your head see true that's
that's Mike's a sad one that was good
yeah I like this that's that's why were
you're trying to be quiet with the
roommates in the room next to you you're
like no you have the music
oh yeah play music there you go have you
guys ever got self-conscious the way
that you come after you watched how porn
guys come and you're like that's how I
should express myself how about the
waiting [ __ ] chicks and the way the
chicks are coming like they're falling
down a mountain yeah [ __ ] hate that
so much I used to think sex was like
that for me though like I thought I had
to do that to like show that that's like
you're communicating the right way so I
would [ __ ] go
I'd I would you show like that so the
person is both on both sides after all
porn bucks it up yeah
porno messes up the whole experience man
cuz I'm like damn these chicks aren't
[ __ ] like the falling out of a hot
air balloon when I'm [ __ ] them it
just makes me yeah but just makes you
insecure is when you're when you're a
teenager yeah yeah oh yes I'm going back
to my original why I asked Casey that
because you actually when you told me
about the whole introvert thing right
you kill it as a host you kill it as a
hose it's [ __ ] good none of us can
even tell right but what's the process
that goes through your head when when
you're up here cuz you're obviously
internally you're uncomfortable but to
me you look comfortable and you're
killing it so I guess like for all the
introverts that are watching you know
they might relate with you cuz me being
an extrovert this is just easy it's
natural so I guess I'm trying to like
get a little magnifying glass and seeing
inside what what's what's happening in
there well that's a fantastic question
Joe I don't have a thanks for putting me
on the spot Joe cool well I got the hot
potato uh kinda like now you know my
guys the pressures on and I got I got to
just say some words and you know
I don't know can you tell if I'm an
introvert it feels like you're talking
everything's coming up properly wait
ahead of it are you guys because you
three are extroverts I mean introverts
introverts yeah yeah we're all
introverts on this side yes yeah yeah I
don't know about know each other over
here
yes um awfully quiet huh huh for
extroverts make sure hi
and I'm never what please take that back
sure thank you you never stop talking
what sitting is but sitting there or
like or like drawing attention to
yourself as an introvert is the last
thing you want because then the room
gets quiet like this yeah and then
people are listening that quiet well for
an introvert it's really really cool
sitting there it's like the whole room
revolves around you like I kind of run
the show and then like and if there's a
a lull you know you're kinda like oh
[ __ ] up say something you know get it
going again you know we're not which is
not generally the strength of an
introvert you know an introvert I feel
like it's your fault for the quietness
drove that true pressure I like a lull
nothing wrong with the law firm what's
that what's that like wouldn't when a
conversations kind of just when you when
everyone's laughing like like when I'm
having a good conversation with somebody
usually there are little moments where
it's fine it's not awkward like when
you're having tea with your mom and [ __ ]
you go yeah good days
you guys can stare at each other and he
goes so do you guys get awkward whenever
you guys are like riding in a car in
just like you're in another person and
then just just like no words being
spoken if I want to breathe vibration is
awkward then yeah yeah what's awkward
belly just be quiet or like what the
person or if they say like say yeah
would they go or something and she's
like cool you feel comfortable with her
then it's awkward so you guys feel the
need to fill the space and the
awkwardness or like it's it's on you to
do so yeah not all the time you might
develop the person III do feel what
NASA's saying in terms of like your
relationship with that person will
determine like your comfort level and
then how you're gonna want to talk or
not talk yeah um that first sure is one
of those things but I don't always feel
like I have to talk mm-hmm depends on
the person
driving and breathing driving and
breathing is nice like when you just
sometimes talkin and you just take a
break and listen to the song yeah oh not
even having music though
oh yeah just listen to the road you can
you sit in her car with someone else
not having music on you just hear like
the hum of the highway or whatever and
it's just [ __ ] quiet okay is that
awkward too
I can but I think I talk regardless even
when I'm alone sure so I'll be like
that's a [ __ ] tree dude bug and
you're naked this sitting at your piano
yeah right out of the shower that's my
thing right I love I like the quiet
sometimes like it's totally fine
especially if something's naturally just
not like everyone's being kind of
reflective in the car anyway like I
don't have a problem that I though one
time me and Nikki we were trying to just
go to the beach and relax we went to her
aunt's house and they went with us and
they would not stop talking the entire
[ __ ] time to the point where like if
a boat went by the like although that
blue boat oh that house back there used
to be white but this is painted it like
60 like chit chat right old chick old
people chit chat love to do [ __ ] like
that they don't have anyone else to talk
to you and I totally get it and and I
it's it was just funny but also it
sucked because we just went there to
chill like we went there not to talk we
went that is to relax and breathe be
chair and lay back I feel like I'm like
an introvert extrovert like the mixture
because I feel like I need conversations
that I need interactions with people but
it's with people that I place higher
with value right so like friends of mine
family of mine where I want it I feel
like I need to and I want to speak with
them I feel like I need I needed some
kind of interaction all the time so no
losers I can't just be locked in a house
for like a week straight and like not
talk to anybody that drives me crazy so
I in that sense I don't feel like I'm an
introvert because I know a lot of people
are perfectly comfortable and fine doing
that so what am i then cuz I [ __ ]
love quarantine right now and I went a
week without any human interaction like
maybe some lives your extroverted with
[ __ ] multiple personality disorder
yeah but how long did it take before you
started driving around town delivering
lemons
I'm just kidding no I mean like after
though there's been days where I'm just
completely who you're actually there's
so many different types of people but I
think you're also comfortable with being
alone with yourself that's not just a
whole introvert thing because I'm
servers also need people true like I
needed to talk to true dude during the
quarantine I'm like oh is this kind of
nuts that's where you came over with
Isaac huh they need to control their own
environment well they don't want to do
things that put them out of the element
but I'm more like Nelson where I would
rather have deep meaningful
conversations with people then talk
about the tree or the [ __ ] and how
the house got painted like that [ __ ] I'd
rather not talk well that's as everyone
for that for that conversation right
like let's start with the tree and then
hopefully will and some people like are
perfectly fun with doing like small talk
all day long with a bunch of strangers
that's exhausting because it means
nothing like that can you punch them Oh
true
okay that's a hot tip thank you yeah
we're just cut back on all the [ __ ]
go to straight like deep conversation
yeah you mentioned that yesterday just
ask him what religion they're yeah yeah
go straight do it that's great
Democrat Republican right to the traits
of the kinda not a fan of Jews
personally that's how you just do I
don't know what to say but if they're
like yeah me neither
[Laughter]
I have so many new friends now I kind of
like the position of hosts sometimes
only because it's new to me but also I
get to think like long game like if
we're having a conversation right and
let's say something stands out to me
that's really interesting
then I can really drive the attention
toward that way or that question and
it's maybe that's the difference between
extrovert and introvert is like
extrovert might feel like puppet master
where introvert feels the need to
perform individually I think it's
opposite he said you said introvert is
wants to perform and then extrovert is
like Popeye master I feel like introvert
is puppet master where they set things
up
we're actually where it just as about
themselves
just loud one oh it's like it's like
hosting a party like the difference
between me and TIFF when we when you
guys come over to our house is for me
I'm like alright food's gotta be there
this is gotta be there I gotta make sure
everything's okay everyone's happy or
whatever and TIFF is just comfortable
making the rounds and just talking to
people so her extrovert itself comes out
where I'm like I'm introverted I'm just
like I feel more comfortable just making
sure everyone's happy and like you know
I find the happiness and like my
Megastore everyone else is good yeah I
don't if hosting would be an introverted
extroverted thing cuz I hosted JK party
and that she was but I've liked the
hosting cuz it was just like finding
like what if this [ __ ] don't even exist
what does it introvert what it was like
horoscopes and [ __ ] people just making
up [ __ ] they're like yeah I'm kind of an
Aries you know like I mean any kind of
label is like that right yeah and you
identify it and then you just like hey
guys I'm an introvert I mean the problem
I have a labels is I think it's fine for
people to use them to like identify with
but not to pigeon-holed themselves you
know because it's the worst when people
are like I'm an int v2 fsj and they're
like this is how I am forever what I
love hiding behind my ears
this is how they are forever and I'm
like that you can change yourself all
the time I take it or leave it I'm an
[ __ ] it says in my horoscope [ __ ]
I'm an Aries that's true though some
people are like that they're like I'm a
Gemini I'm kind of crazy okay sometimes
I go back and forth other than that and
you're like that one excuse to be a
bright clean it up yeah that's true
you're leaning all the way back on it I
had this girl on Twitter as I followed
her and I had on Father because
everything she did was like horoscope
yeah wouldn't it just like making
excuses for herself because her or
school an excuse a [ __ ] about some for
talking [ __ ] and then when she talks
[ __ ] and people like yo you were just
talking [ __ ] like oh she goes I can't
help I'm a Scorpio oh yeah I'm a Scorpio
I'm supposed to talk [ __ ] yeah no dude
that's Irish guys end up fighting too
but oh I can't help but I'm Irish yeah
it's a cool thing to have though man
get drunk and fight I can up it it's you
know Irish only I wanted to be Irish I
am how much Irish I don't even know you
23andme
I should have you ever been in a fight
not a real fight no like an argument
match I've been in like like when you're
in middle school and you're [ __ ]
throwing people against the lockers and
[ __ ] like shoving people things do you
think you're high like because you grew
real quick right when you're a little so
then do you think your height had a lot
to do with not being bullied and I just
think that I'd was never that guy who's
like don't disrespect me or anything
like that I am NOT that guy I was never
starting anything up or like that so
yours is self defense when you draw
people into lockers I had to do it one
time this kid who was who would not stop
bullying me we were part of a basketball
team together and so finally I just
[ __ ] had it one day he's your height
then - all right use a little shorter
than me yeah he was pissed action
because I got the basketball team and he
didn't and I sucked at basketball I
definitely got a team because I was
taller it wasn't my fault
same and the coach picked me and then
coach coach we need tall guy right he's
like you'll be a rebound guy does Rodman
or whatever so yeah this guy would would
every single day call me names and like
they wouldn't let me sit with the
basketball team and stuff it suck but he
wasn't even honest he was the anonymity
but all of all his friends were on it
too and so I took his spot in all the
[ __ ] so one day I had to shove him up
against the locker and just be like you
know [ __ ] off leave me the [ __ ] alone
and he did it after that actually I feel
like a lot of times with those
situations because I had a situation now
similar I think a lot of times when
people bully you they don't even realize
that it's like affecting you in a
negative way for some reason I got the
same situation I remember this one guy
was like giving me [ __ ] every day right
and I remember I was finishing up in my
locker and he was giving me [ __ ] from
like a few feet away so I went over and
punched him really hard and then he got
mad out of nowhere right so he starts
swinging back out of nowhere and I was
like backing up so the point where I
just walked away and then he never
picked on me again after that it was
just like I think a lot of times they're
just like oh I'm just I'm just [ __ ]
around and then later on they're like oh
[ __ ] that guy got really mad how that
was your fight that he was sweet on you
along the way well I think it hunches
were just emotional you know so he's
just started swinging and I could just
like back up like back up while he was
sweet he was just miss so he wasn't like
calculating the punches it was like
reactionary yeah that's pretty cool a
dude years later that Khopoli kid tried
to ask me to get him to like this improv
team that I was in and I was just like I
can't believe you don't even [ __ ]
remember how much you came down on me
all the time but I think it's like you
were saying like I don't think they even
know yeah I remember being a bully
specifically I target or the bully i
targeted big people in elementary school
cuz I was like fat people bigger just
big people or more aggressive people cuz
I thought that if I could dominate a
bully that nobody will [ __ ] so you had
like to chew all of mentality yeah I was
a big Chihuahua and if I couldn't do it
then I befriended someone that was even
a bigger bully and I manipulated them to
bully that guy and yeah so I was quite
the Joe Pesci and I stopped doing it
later because it didn't really work it
didn't stop other people from bullying
me yeah I noticed a lot of people like
would pick on others just to make
themselves feel better like that's the
most bullies are getting bullied yeah so
like I remember I would see all the time
it's most of the time when people are
bullies they're like they're not all the
way up the ladder
they're like somewhere in the bottom
half and they're like alright if I pick
on these people not like go thinking
they're picking on other people but if I
make fun of them
then I'm better than somebody yeah yeah
and like or I could be top dog here
while I'm bottom at home yeah you know
cuz at home they're getting abused or
others a lot of that so oh yeah my
father would [ __ ] me up every single day
I got home so I think it's one of those
things man it's a bully's probably are
getting bullied for sure
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]